now to breaking news in the dramatic
downfall of a one-time cryptocurrency
billionaire 30 year old Sam bankman
freed has been arrested in the Bahamas
on multiple charges of fraud related to
his crypto exchange FTX billions of
dollars remain unaccounted for in a case
that's casting a huge Shadow over the
entire crypto industry in an SEC
complaint just released this morning
Regulators wrote this we allege that Sam
bankman freed built a house of cards on
a foundation of deception while telling
investors that it was one of the safest
buildings in crypto Scott McFarland is
following all this in Washington Scott
good morning this has been quite a story
it is Gail good morning the Securities
and Exchange Commission charges bankman
freed with orchestrating a scheme to
defraud investors in a parallel action
this morning a federal court in New York
will unseal criminal charges against him
as scrutiny grows over a man whose
business imploded in a matter of weeks
in the emerging intricate world of
cryptocurrency Sam bankman freed was
King running FTX one of the world's
largest exchanges until all of a sudden
in November the company fell apart and
the King was dethroned and he spoke out
about it last month
I screwed up like
Iowa CEO I I was a CEO of FTX and I mean
that means that I was responsible
ultimately frustrating the right things
and I mean I we didn't investors lost
billions and FTX fell into bankruptcy
the CEO who'd replace bankman freed
blamed the company's failure on grossly
inexperienced and unsophisticated
individuals the nation's treasury
secretary spoke with Nora O'Donnell on
60 Minutes about the failure before
bankman Freed's Arrest A lot of people
have lost a lot of money and from the
details that I'm aware of the controls
were utterly lacking consumer
protections that
um Americans expect to be in place
um resembling not there
um importantly this company mainly
operated in the Bahamas and I think that
wasn't an accident we do have
protections
um and some of whom may even applied to
crypto exchanges in the United States
bankman freed who ran the business in
the Bahamas was scheduled to appear
before the U.S House Financial Services
committee today to be put under oath and
answer questions about the failure of
his company and the shock wave it sent
through the digital currency industry
but at the request of American
authorities police in the Bahamas took
him into custody late yesterday to face
federal charges including violating
Securities laws here in the U.S
it remains unclear when bankman freed
will be handed over to U.S authorities
but it's quite clear Congress is
considering tighter rules and
regulations for this emerging industry
to prevent future crises from taking
down other multi-billion dollar
companies Tony
tighter rules might be wise Scott thank
you very much